Rhonda's with us in Dayton Ohio
hi Rhonda how are you I'm great how are
you better than I deserve what's up
awesome well I had a combination
question um because I too have read the
love and respects us by dr. English and
I just wondering what to do with my life
in my husband we've been married for
quite a while and we cannot get on the
same page financially we've not been
able to do this for over 30 years
there's dead out there
and most of us honestly student loan
debt we don't have any car payments I
don't even couldn't tell you how much he
actually makes right now because we have
so many issues with that and I know it's
a marriage problem I get it mm-hmm I
can't I don't know what to do to get
through the problem mm-hmm and I need
your advice okay well I don't know that
there's one magic pill here because this
is these ruts are pretty deep there 30
years deep yeah and so jumping up out of
that rut is not a not an easy thing it's
probably a lot tougher than just a
gallon of radio is going to get you
signed up for yeah but but I think
there's two things that go on one is he
what's your husband do for a living he's
a financial adviser okay which makes it
even harder because he won't talk to you
when we won't read your book and I
actually bought your book for all of my
children it's not this is not about me
okay this is about you know I'm gonna be
okay whether your husband reads my books
or not I'll be all right
okay don't worry about me but the the
thing is the point is though that his
wife as being completely discounted and
your vote doesn't count
your husband's arrogant and he doesn't
need your input either and that needs to
change for your sake because you're
gonna blow up one of these days and
we're not gonna get you to land back on
this play
in it it's gonna eventually you're gonna
go there and I I've met people 35 years
later get divorced I mean you don't want
to do that so I think but most of the
time most husbands are good guys most of
them and he's just not hearing you that
this is as serious as it is and so I
think you need to start explaining it to
him that this is very serious and you're
not going to be okay with this
continuing this way and I think you
think you nails need to sit down with a
marriage counselor if he won't go you
need to go without him and get some
advice on how to deal with him that's
better than advice I can give you good
solid marriage counseling is in
desperate need here this is the Dave
Ramsey show